the man known as Jackie Chan is one of
the biggest and most badass
movie stars ever and the first bridge
the gap between Hong Kong action cinema
and big-budget
American movies Chan might be passed to
60 but he's still putting his life on
the line to thrill audiences read the
womb though it may seem like the big
screen legend has been around forever
Jackie Chan was born Chan Khong sang in
April 1954 it was nothing weird about
that until you realize he was supposed
to be born in January of that year yup
he hung out in his mother's womb for a
full 12 months before a British doctor
had to surgically remove him at the time
of his forced birth he weighed 12 pounds
his mother nicknamed him pow pow or
cannonball my wife had such a difficult
time delivering him after she was
totally exhausted the nurse brought the
baby in saying oh he's so cute just like
a cannonball nevertheless that kind of
medical procedure isn't cheap and Chan's
parents couldn't afford it thus they
tried to sell their baby to the doctor
who delivered him the doctor said no
obviously
according to chance memoir his parents
gathered the money from their friends
and needed a decade to pay them all back
learning from legends when Jackie Chan
was seven years old he was enrolled and
boarded at the China drama Academy where
he was taught acting and singing in
preparation for a career in the paid
King Opera it was their chant lived and
trained for the next 10 years eventually
forming an acrobatic troupe with some
classmates called the seven little
fortunes upon leaving school Chad used
the group to gain his first roles in
Hong Kong movies he and the seven little
fortunes were extras and stuntmen in
Enter the Dragon and fists of fury two
of the most famous and popular movies
ever made by Bruce Lee Chan even got to
spar on camera with this screen legend
satiny my eyes are black because he's
just one stick right on my hair
picky with voice parts while a star in
Asia since the 1970s Jackie Chan wasn't
a mainstream star in the US until the
release of rumble in the Bronx in 1996
before that he helped bring American
movies to Asia for example he provided
the Mandarin language voice acting of
the based for the Chinese dub of BG and
the based China's since done voice work
in the english-language releases of
other major animated movies one notable
example being his portrayal of master
monkey in the Kung Fu Panda movies
however you might be surprised to hear
of the one place he didn't lend his
voice the cartoon series Jackie Chan
adventures although he appeared in
live-action bumpers for the show the
cartoon version of Jackie Chan is voiced
by James see know anything Apple
children who also incidentally took over
his master monkey in the TV series
spin-off of Kung Fu Panda to make things
even more confusing the character of
Jade Chan Jackie's fictional niece on
the series was voiced by Stacy chair
Jackie Chan's real-life niece no
stranger to danger after starring in
dozens of martial arts into action
movies in which he's done his own stunts
Jackie Chan has sustained a number of
injuries so much so that in 2013 his
movie Chinese zodiac was promoted in
Japan with a poster that consisted of an
image of Chan's body with arrows
pointing to all of his injured body
parts among the injuries Chan has
suffered in the pursuit of entertainment
on drunken master he damaged a bone
behind his eyebrow and it nearly blinded
him on City Hunter he dislocated his
right shoulder on the armor of God Chan
fell out of a tree and suffered a skull
fracture a bone cave in behind the ear
and bleeding into his brain during
surgery bone chips were removed from his
head two finger two fingers yeah take
these two fingers bowling with Jackie
Chan oh my god yes yes yes yes he broke
his breastbone on armor of God too
during the filming of the accidental spy
he broke his tailbone who was
temporarily paralyzed
oh and he's broken his nose four
separate times once while making the
young master once on project day
once on miracle
and one son mr. nice guy ouch
we'll never complain about a stubbed toe
again broken broken he's gone
jaws kick broken broken broken crack
crack crack crack but the one thousand
times a charm directors may require a
lot to get the scene the way they want
to in one example of this borderline
abusive practice Stanley Kubrick
infamously required Shelley Duvall to
film one scene in The Shining 127 times
by that logic the most sadistic director
that Jackie Chan has ever worked with is
himself while directing and starring in
the 1982 movie Dragon Lord a sequence in
which characters play Jeon Z a Chinese
sports similar to hacky sack but with a
weighted badminton style shuttlecock
just didn't look right to direct a chair
it's been reported the same took 2,900
cakes but it probably didn't take that
many the book kung-fu masters places the
number over 190 and other estimates come
in at over 1000 either way
chanting was dedicated to the shot tough
love Jackie Chan's a movie star which
means he's rich he's a master fortune of
over three hundred and fifty million
dollars in addition to earning salary
and box office percentages from his
films he's owned a chain of movie
theaters and a Segway dealership and
when he dies a lot of it is going to
charity but his son JC chair who was
convicted on drug charges in 2015 stands
to inherit exactly none of that
in 2011 Chan publicly mentioned that he
won't leave his fortune behind to his
son remarking if he is capable he can
make his own money if he is not then he
will be just wasting my money it seems
like there's a little more to the story
than that especially considering the
fact that their relationship isn't
without its past bumps in the road
Jackie once even admitted that he had
beaten JC when he was a child
admitting that he was not a mortal
father but it looks like threats of
violence are offered
these days we're in the way short
running around because if you don't
watch his old hilltops every shot
no I can no Sami polarizing politics
while Jackie Chan boasts fans from every
corner of the globe he's still very
loyal to his home nation of China's
political system of communist in fact
he's way more politically outspoken than
most of his fans probably realized he's
even opened up about his opinions on the
American Way of life on more than one
occasion
in 2013 he said what I can see is China
continuously making progress in learning
if you talk about corruption the entire
world the United States has no
corruption it's the most corrupt in the
world but his opinions don't ends with
the u.s. in 2009 he talked about the
dangers of too much freedom in China
controlled Taiwan saying I don't know
whether it's better to have freedom or
to have no freedom with too much freedom
it gets very chaotic it could end up
like in Taiwan Chinese people need to be
controlled otherwise they will do
whatever they want whether you agree or
disagree with chairs beliefs one thing's
for certain he knows how to get pulses
racing no matter where his fans fall on
the political spectrum
[Music]